مع استمرار انتشار فيروس كورونا الجديد في
جميع أنحاء العالم
وتزايد عدد القتلى هؤلاء العلماء في ألمانيا
مثل عدد لا يحصى من الآخرين في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، في سباق مع الزمن في محاولة
لتطوير لقاح بأسرع ما يمكن
لمرض لدى العالم العلمي
الكثير ليقوم به  تعرف جيدًا على التحدي
أولاً وقبل كل شيء هو أن الفيروس غير
معروف ، لذا فأنت لا تعرف نوع
الحماية التي تحتاجها
لتحفيز جهاز المناعة من
أجل حماية الشركة الألمانية الأمريكية.
البيت للقاء الرئيس ترامب يصنع
اللقاحات من خلال دمج
رمز الفيروس بشكل أساسي في الخلايا البشرية
لمساعدة الجسم على حماية نفسه ، ونحن
نجعل الجسم لإنتاج لقاح
خاص بك ، كل من هذه الأنابيب الصغيرة
تحتوي على بنية مختلفة من
رمز الفيروس الصحيح  يحاول العلماء الآن
في المختبر الرئيسي في ألمانيا
معرفة أيهما أكثر أمانًا
وفعالية ليتم تحويله إلى
لقاح جيدًا.  لا أريد تحديد
موعد لذلك ، لكنهم يعتقدون أنهم
يقتربون من ذلك ، فنحن
نستعد لتجربة إكلينيكية من بين التركيبات المختلفة
التي يجب علينا إدخال أفضلها
في العيادات ، ونحن في
مناقشات مستمرة مع السلطات التنظيمية
لا يمكن أن يكون الضغط
أعلى مع ارتفاع عدد
حالات الإصابة بفيروس كورونا الجديد كل يوم وتعرض
الاقتصاد العالمي
لضربات من تأثيرات فيروسات كورونا ، حث الرئيس
ترامب في اجتماع مع صانعي الأدوية
الصناعة على ابتكار
لقاح في أسرع وقت ممكن.  بقوة
لتسريع عملية
تطوير لقاح ، هناك الكثير من الأشياء الجيدة التي
تحدث وتحدث بسرعة كبيرة ، وقلت
سأفعل لي معروفاً لتسريع العملية
، وسنحتاج إلى الاستعداد
بينما يقر مسؤولو الصحة في الولايات المتحدة بأن الأمر
سيكون على الأقل.  قبل عام من
الحصول على الشهادة ، تقول الشركة إنها
تعمل وقتًا إضافيًا لإنجازها قريبًا
إذا قارنت تطوير لقاح طبيعي
يستغرق عدة سنوات ، فنحن
نكافح  في الوقت الحالي ، وبالتالي فإن
السلطات التنظيمية تعمل
وتحاول القيام بذلك في غضون عام واحد
كمركز نقل رئيسي للصين
والعالم تعاني هونغ كونغ ،
وعلى مدرج المطار في مطار هونغ كونغ
الدولي ، يمكنك
رؤية الرسوم بوضوح.  من
تفشي فيروس كورونا ، حيث صورنا صفوفًا من
عشرات وعشرات طائرات كاثي المحطمة
وفقًا لدراسة أجرتها صحيفة South
China Morning Post ، ألغت شركة الطيران الرئيسية في المدينة
أكثر من
ثلاثة أرباع رحلاتها الأسبوعية في
مارس في غضون ذلك داخل هونغ كونغ
في المطار الدولي ، ستشاهد
طاقم لوحة المحطات الشاسع الفارغ هذا
وعرضًا للرحلة مع الإلغاء بعد
الإلغاء ، صور صارخة للصناعة
التي ضربها الفيروس ،
وقالت كاثي الأسبوع الماضي إن 75 ٪ من موظفيها
سيأخذون إجازة غير مدفوعة الأجر تؤثر على حوالي
25000 موظف.
حقل جارا النفطي في شرق المملكة
العربية السعودية هو ما ساعد في بناء
سمعة المملكة باعتبارها
المصدر الأول في العالم  كان حقله
ملك القلعة إذا كنت ستفعل ذلك لعقود
ولا يزال ينتج ما يقرب من أربعة
ملايين برميل يوميًا ولكن ارتفاع
الإنتاج في الولايات المتحدة
والنرويج والبرازيل يجعل الحياة أكثر
تعقيدًا لمنتجي أوبك بلس
وكان هذا قبل فيروس كورونا
هي عاصفة كاملة اجتاحت الأسعار
في منطقة السوق الهابطة
وكان الحديث على الأرض في
مؤتمر الطاقة الكبير هذا في الرياض ، فإن
فيروس كورنو له تأثير كبير
على الطلب على النفط الذي يأتي على رأس
أسواق النفط المزودة بالفعل بكثرة
ويتزايد عدم  إنتاج الأوبك ، لذا فإن
تأثير السوق هذا يتضاعف بشكل أساسي
من جانب الطلب والعرض ، ما
مدى
سوء مشاريع وكالة الطاقة الدولية في أول انخفاض ربع سنوي
في الطلب منذ عام 2009 عندما بدأت
الأزمة المالية العالمية بعد
ارتفاع الأسعار بسبب التوترات الأمنية الإيرانية
في وقت مبكر  كانون الثاني (يناير)
خسر المؤشر الدولي ما يقرب
من 20 دولارًا للبرميل مع ظهور فيروس كورونا
سريعًا وخلق
فوضى في السوق  قد يجعل apse بدوره
مهمة الرئيس الفعلي لأوبك بالإضافة إلى
وزير الطاقة السعودي عبد العزيز
بن سلمان أسهل قليلاً دون الاضطرار إلى
تسليح 22 منتجًا آخرين
خاصة روسيا لإجراء
تخفيضات إنتاج أعمق
تفرضها الصين جزئيًا.  قامت أكبر مستورد للنفط في العالم
بالفعل بتخفيض الشحنات
حيث توقف النمو مخاوف مماثلة
ابتليت بها كوريا الجنوبية واليابان هنا
في شبه الجزيرة العربية ،
ترى شركات النفط الوطنية هذه عمليات البيع في نفس
السياق الذي كان عليه قبل عقد من الزمان ومرة أخرى خلال ان
يار أسعار النفط لعام 2016.  ال
في وجه العاصفة باعتبارنا المنتجين الأقل تكلفة في العالم ، فإن
مهمتنا في هذه المرحلة
الزمنية وفي جميع الأوقات هي أن نبقى
سريعًا للغاية ومرنًا للغاية ، ولكن نظرًا لارتفاع
نفقات الميزانية في الشرق الأوسط الأوسع ،
لا أحد يستفيد من هزيمة السوق
مثل هذا جون  شهدت مناطق Tefft
نشاطًا تجاريًا في مجال جاما في المملكة
العربية السعودية